[Music]
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that dancing this
is dancing what
is happening i'm defusing the situation
[Applause]
oh why is my phone always dead i paid 13
for it
don't worry i got it oh no my hands are
covered in butter from making butter
i'm on it record must record
camera on all right here we go dancing
over
situation diffused
[Music]
my windshield but it belongs in here hey
thank you creed you really got this
place no problem
i just have no idea who's driving behind
me now
[Music]
let's take the back and go for yours on
my command now hit the dance floor it's
gonna make a sweater
[Music]
here we go
here we go
[Music]
you don't stand a chance i'm gonna turn
jeffords junction into the funnest town
in america
that's right i said funnest
stop dancing stop dancing
this is a direct order stop
dancing
[Applause]
this place is outstanding great call
leslie knope
look even ben's dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
dance for me
[Music]
i know you're in a lot of pain but we
don't have any meds here you just got to
try not to focus on it can you distract
her i got this
hey me they come out with any new
binders recently i don't want to talk
about binders rosa all right that was my
big gun she's just gonna feel this
not necessarily i was just checking to
see if there's anything we can do to
help
and i hate to say it but i think there
is oh you think he's going to get me
drugs from evidence
uh no something way weirder is happening
hit it jeffords
[Music]
distracted
[Music]
oh
wow thank you now it's time for the
dance contest
we do that after i do my presentation
nope
dance contest all right we'll have a
motivational dance contest
hit it yeah okay
dancing it is a primal
art form used in ancient times
to express yourself with the body
and communicate
sometimes you have to take a break from
being the kind of boss that's always
trying to teach people things
sometimes you have to just be the boss
of dancing
[Music]
santiago your test result from the
sergeant's exam has arrived ooh
everybody make room amy needs adequate
space to do her signature dork dance
i don't know if there's gonna be a dork
dance oh look how small that envelope is
that's not a big good news envelope
that's a little bad news envelope what
that's nuts
sarge tell her envelope size doesn't
matter if i'm being honest i got a much
bigger envelope oh god
unhelpful terry very unhelpful mine was
bigger too okay i just won't ever open
it that way i'll never get rejected
fine i'll open it no no no
do it harder i opened it you passed oh
oh my god i'm gonna be a surgeon you're
gonna be a sergeant yes
no it's happening
yeah that's my future wife
so where's chris i told him that one
headlight by the wall flowers isn't
dancing music and he said not with that
attitude
[Music]
of course
why don't we have a talent show then who
has a special talent
oh i just learned a single ladies dance
hey yes
people love it look at that two painted
ladies just joined in
you gotta admit boyle really knows how
to move his pelvis
i can't believe this is one of the last
things i'm ever gonna see
look what i can do with my feet baby
oh my god the captain he could really
win this thing
how did you get so amazing at dancing
jake focus
i found a back stairway over here and
spin
who is he dance dance dance dance
you don't have to say dance every time
you make a step good call
hey do you want me to actually show you
how to do this so you don't
hurt yourself and possibly others yes
ready
[Music]
it's kind of fun
martha i want to lease this house
great thought i was going to be more
dramatic than that
hold on okay say it again martha
i want to lease this house
[Music]
okay ready everybody hit it red
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you and
[Music]
you